Speaker 1: Why don't we keep it going?
It's hard to imagine we could keep such a
streak going today, but I'm really going to
try.
Let's go to and I know that last time I mispronounced
your name, is it to Meesha from New York City.
Yes, Tamasha, how are you?
Speaker 3: Hi, how are you doing?
David, do you know why I like you so much?
Speaker 1: No, I'm shocked you do, to be honest.
Speaker 3: No, I like you because I think
of things and I see things happening, and
then I go to watch a video of yours and you
think exactly are similar to the way I think,
OK.
But I wanted to ask you a question about.
I know that there's been a policy in the talks
about free college.
I know Biden was talking about community colleges
being free.
Yeah, I know some people talk about state
colleges.
And when I talk to my friends about it, I
say, oh, my son was 11.
By the time he goes to college, it'll be free.
And when we talk about college funds.
But then they told me that college is only
free for, like, the really, really poor.
Is that true, that it won't be like everybody
has access to that?
Speaker 1: Well, the thing the thing that's
difficult to measure is that we don't know
yet because there are proposals, there are
proposals for full free state college regardless
of income.
There are proposals for means tested programs
where if family income is above a certain
amount, then it's not free, but below that
amount it is free.
But what I will tell you is this.
Every proposal I've seen from any any serious
Democrat would be at least free community
college below very.
It won't only be for people under the federal
poverty line.
It won't be that it'll be free for a significant
portion of the population.
The real question is, will this pass?
I have no idea.
We just don't know yet.
For now, there's you know, nothing has passed.
So if it were me right now and I don't have
a kid right now to save for college, I would
be operating financially under the assumption
that college would not be free for them.
And, hey, you know what?
If it ends up being free, that's great.
Speaker 3: Well, yeah, I guess I'm being optimistic.
Yeah, of course, I do agree with you that
you should plan for any outcome.
Yes, but and I think I find, like, the fact
that it wouldn't be like the income part of
it bothers me only a little bit because, you
know, most people, even if you have a decent
salary, you still fall and you're still not
necessarily rich.
Of course, when you know, even if you have
a decent salary and those people still tend
to be forgotten.
Speaker 1: No doubt, and this was an issue
sometimes, you know, with with Obamacare in
many states, the way that the subsidies are
set, there's no I don't remember what state
it was, but there are states where the subsidies,
if you're a self-employed person and you have
to go and buy a plan on the health care market,
you get a really big subsidy.
If you earn under ten thousand dollars a year
and a smaller subsidy between 10 and 20 and
a smaller subsidy between 20 and 30.
But like by the time you get to forty eight
thousand dollars a year, the subsidy ends.
So basically, if you earn forty eight thousand
dollars a year, eighty eight thousand dollars
a year or eight hundred and eighty eight thousand
dollars a year, everybody gets no subsidy.
Once you get to forty eight, that seems terrible.
It's that middle that really gets squeezed
in that situation.
And so something to be aware of.
And let's hope that it doesn't happen if indeed
there's a college funding plan put put together.
Speaker 3: Yes, hopefully.
One more thing.
I know you talked about this a week or so
ago, two weeks maybe about the mayor in Chicago.
I think it was what she was saying, that she
would only
Speaker 1: she would only be interviewed by
nonwhite journalists.
Speaker 3: Yeah.
And I agree with you where I feel like if
you discriminate, if you are calling out discrimination
by using discrimination, and that's not only
hypocritical, but it defeats the purpose.
Yes.
But also from another perspective, I think
I'm I'm guessing I can't speak for her, but
I'm thinking that since, you know, the history
of blacks in this country is where we're seen
as less than we're seen as not human in the
past or were seen as a stupid, lazy like those
are some of the stereotypes.
I think that that what she was trying to do
or what maybe she's trying to do is say we're
trying to I'm trying to even the playing field
and give us an upper hand.
We're always
Speaker 1: upper hand.
Yeah.
And to clarify on that, to me, for people
who don't know, Chicago Mayor Lori Lightfoot
said that around.
I don't remember if it was just like around
Memorial Day or what it was.
She said that she was only going to be interviewed
by nonwhite journalists for this short period
of time and interview requests by white journalists
would be rejected.
Now, what I said at the time was, if this
is just a policy, this is this is just racism
and I'm against it completely.
However, if it had been presented as, hey,
you know what, this is a city, the city of
Chicago, which has a huge nonwhite population.
And yet most of the interviews with elected
officials that show up in the newspapers are
with white journalists.
So for this one week, I am going to prioritize
being interviewed by journalists of color.
Great, beautiful.
However, the way that it was said was I will
be rejecting interview requests from white
journalists.
And you know what?
I just think it was it was completely, improperly
framed.
And I agree with you that there's a right
way to do this and there's a wrong way to
do this.
Speaker 3: Yeah, and that's basically what
is trying to figure out the right way.
Yeah.
So give us an even playing field, because
most of the time what when black people are
asking for is equality not necessarily a handout.
Right.
We take it.
It's just to even the playing field.
I'm with you.
That's not always the right way to do it.
I agree with you.
Speaker 1: All right, Tamika, always great
to hear from you.
Thank you.
All right.
There is to Meesha.
Let's take a quick break.
If you're holding, don't hang up.
We're going to try to keep the streak of perfect
phone calls going right after this short break